معارك عنيفه في بخموت ومحاور اخرى
واوكرانيا تتحدث عن احباط خمس وثمانين
هجوم روسيا
رصد 19 طائره تابعه للقوات الجويه الصينيه
في منطقه الدفاع الجوي التايوانيه
لتجاوز التحديات عبر الحوار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
احباطها 85 هجوما روسيا في محاور كوبيانس
وخاركاف
واوضحت ان القوات الجويه نفذت 11 غاره على
اهداف روسيه خلال 24 ساعه هذا واشنت روسيا
68 هجوما من منظومات الصواريخ مما ادى الى
اصابه مدنيين كما اصابت راجمات الصواريخ
والمدفعيه 9 مناطق تمركز قوه بشريه ومنطقه
تمركز اسلحه وعسكريه واشارت هيئه الاركان
الى ان مستوى تهديد الضربات الصاروخيه
الروسيه لا يزال مرتفعا في جميع انحاء
اوكرانيا
وفي سلسله احتدام المعارك في مدينه بخموت
شرق اوكرانيا كثف الجيش الروسي الهجمات
لمحاصره المدينه حتى تمكن من قطع ثلاث طرق
اوكرانيه لعبور الامدادات اما الجانب
الاوكراني فقد وصف الاوضاع بالمتوتره
للغايه الجيش الروسي افاد باطلاق طائرات
مسيره استهدفت البنى التحتيه المدنيه
مشيرا الى ان احدى المسيرات استهدفت
العاصمه موسكو للمراه الاولى منذ بدء
الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
هنا في بخمه الاوكرانيه تقترب اطول واشرس
معركه في الحرب من نهايتها حيث تقول
المعلومات والصور القادمه من هناك ان
الخناق يضيق على المقاومين الاوكران ضيق
يقابله اصرار على الصمود حتى النهايه
المدينه الصغيره بحجمها الكبيره في اسمها
وموقعها الاستراتيجي اصبحت ايقونه في
الحرب الدائره منذ عام ورمزيه للانتصار
لمن يسيطر عليها بعد اشهر من الجمود على
طول الجبهات المشتعله شرقا وجنوبا
تقول اخر المعلومات ان قوات فاجنر دخلت
احياء باخمت الشرقيه والوسطى فيما تزال
الاحياء الشماليه بيد الجيش الاوكراني
لتتحول المعركه الى حرب شوارع بين الطرفين
كيف لم تنفي صعوبه الوضع في المدينه شبه
المحاصره لكنها تصر وجيشها على الصمود رغم
شراسه المعارك وموقفها المعقد
يمكن للجميع ان يرى اننا نواجه صعوبه في
هذا القسم الامامي العدو يهاجم باستمرار
في مجموعات صغيره وكبيره فاحيانا يواصلون
القذف المدفعي واليوم التالي يشنون هجمات
المشاهده انه امر صعب لكن اولادنا يستمرون
في الصمود بارضهم
بين ترقب سقوط وقدره على الصمود فالاكيد
ان القتال في باخموت اصبح معركه كسر عظم
بين الطرفين معركه قد تكون انعطافه جديده
لحرب بدات لتوها عامها الثاني
واكد القائم باعمال دونيات
في مدينه
مضيفا ان دبابات لا تختلف عن غيرها من
الاهداف الروسيه
ايضا الى ان ظهور هذا النوع من الدبابات
في بخموت لا يستحق اثاره ضجه كبيره على حد
قوله مبررا ذلك بان الطرق متوحله في الوقت
الحالي ما يتسبب باعاقه حركه دبابات
رجحت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه نفاذ مخزون
روسيا من الطائرات المسيره التي تستخدمها
في عمليتها العسكريه الجاريه حاليا في
اوكرانيا واشارت الوزاره في تقريرها الى
انخفاض وتيره الهجمات الروسيه بمسيارات في
اوكرانيا خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين واشارت
الى انه من المحتمل ان تسعى روسيا لحصول
الحصول على امدادات جديده من الطائرات
المسيره
اشارت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الى تصاعدي حده
المناقشات داخل الكونجرس اثناء الجلسات
الاستماع لكبار المسؤولين في البنتاجون
بشان المساعدات العسكريه التي ارسلتها
الولايات المتحده الى اوكرانيا وقالت
الصحيفه ان اعضاء من الحزبين الجمهوري
والديمقراطي طلبوا من مساعد وزير الدفاع
لشؤون الامن الدولي تقريرا بشان ما زاعم
ضياع الاسلحه وتحويل مسارها خاصه الاسلحه
الاكثر حساسيه لضمان استخدامها للاغراض
المقصوده واكد المفتش العام في البنتاجون
روبرت ستورتش ان المسائله عن الاسلحه
المشحونه لاوكرانيا امر بالغ الاهميه وان
المستويات القياسيه للمساعدات العسكريه
تتطلب مستوى غير مسبوق من الاشراف واضافت
نيويورك تايمز ان هذه الشكوك المتزايده
تهدد ما كان اجماعا قويا من الحزبين لصالح
مساعده اوكرانيا عسكريا ويمكن ان تجعل من
الصعب على اداره بايدن الفوز بموافقه
الكونجرس على تمرير الاموال المطلوبه
لتمويل المساعدات
[تصفيق]
في مقابلته الخاصه مع العربيه تحدث رئيس
الوزراء الاوكراني دينس شمينال عن ملف
محاربه الفساد في بلاده المسؤول الاوكراني
كشف انه خلال الشهر المقبل سيتم تعيين
رئيس لمكتب مكافحه الفساد لمتابعه هذه
القضايا
اربعه اجهزه حكوميه في اوكرانيا الشرطه
والمخابرات ومكتب مكافحه الفساد ومحكمه
مكافحه الفساد وخلال شهر مارس سيتم تعيين
رئيس مكتب مكافحه الفساد في اوكرانيا تكمل
الاجهزه المعنيه التحقيقات في ملفات عده
وانا مقتنع بانه حتى النصف الاول من شهر
مارس ستكون الحكومه وعينت رئيس المكتب
الوطني لمكافحه الفساد
قال النائب الاول لمندوب روسيا في مجلس
الامن ديمتري بوليانسكي ان عددا من الوفود
في مجلس الامن تتغاضى عن افعال من وصفهم
بالارهابيين في شمال غرب سوريا الذين
يمنعون دخول المساعدات وان بعض الاعضاء
يحاولون توجيها اللوم الى روسيا بولياسكي
قال ايضا ان روسيا تعتبر استمرار اسرائيل
في الاستفزازات المسلحه ضد سوريا امرا غير
مقبوله
وضع السفير الفلسطيني في الامم المتحده
رياض منصور مجلس الامن الدولي الى اتخاذ
اجراءات لحمايه المدنيين الفلسطينيين بعد
الهجوم الذي شنه مستوطنون اسرائيليون على
قريه حواره في الضفه الغربيه قلم منصور ان
بلاده ستستمر في الترق باب المجلس ليس فقط
من اجل التحدث بصوت واحد ولكن من اجل ان
يتخذ اجراءات اخرى وان الحمايه هي ما
يطلبه السكان الفلسطينيون
رصدت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه تسعه عشره
طائره تابعه للقوات الجويه الصينيه في
منطقه الدفاع الجوي الخاصه بها ووفق بيان
الوزاره فانها سجلتها في الساعات 24
الماضيه وكلها كانت من طراز جي 10 وصلت
الى الركن الجنوبي الغربي من منطقه الدفاع
الجوي التايوانيه
اكد رئيس وزراء اليابان فوميو كيشيدا ان
خطط تحديث القدرات العسكريه لن تكون
احاديه الجانب ومعتمده على الولايات
المتحده فقط وقال في خطاب بالبرلمان
الياباني ان حكومته تسعى الامتلاك القدره
على تنفيذ هجمات مضاده في اراضي اي عدو
محتمل واشار ايضا الى ان اليابان لن تشارك
في سباق تسلح مع الدول الاخرى
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
ارتفاع وحصيله قتل حادث القطارين في
اليونان الى 32 قتيلا
من جديد في زياره هي الاولى له منذ 6
سنوات وصل امين عام الامم المتحده الى
بغداد
وبعيده وصوله قلج ان زيارته تاتي للتضامن
مع العراقيين والمؤسسات الديمقراطيه
والالتزام في توحيد مؤسسات العراق كما
اعرب عن ثقته بان العراقيين سيتمكنون من
تجاوز الصعوبات والتحديات التي يواجهونها
بفض حوار مفتوح وشامل
وينضم الينا من بغداد مراسل العربيه سامر
الكبيسي اهلا بك سامر يعني ماذا على جدول
لقاء ادغوتيش
في البدايه صباح الخير راويه كان من
المقرر ان يكون هناك مؤتمر صحفي مشترك
لوزير الخارجيه العراقي فؤاد حسين وغوتيش
في مقر وزاره الخارجيه العراقي لكن يبدو
ان الطرفان اكتفيا بما حدث يوم امس او فجر
فجر اليوم عفوا
بالمؤتمر الصحفي الذي عقد في مطار بغداد
الدولي والذي تحدث فيه غوتيرش كذلك تحدث
فيه وزير الخارجيه فؤاد حسين لكن ايضا
بحسب مصادر من وزاره الخارجيه ستكون هناك
لقاءات ثنائيه بين غوتيرش ووزاره الخارجيه
او وزير الخارجيه العراقي فؤاد حسين في
مقر الوزاره بعدها سيكون هناك سلسله من
اللقاءات مع الرئاسات الثلاث وبعض
الفعاليات السياسيه والقاده السياسيين
بحسب ايضا مصادر من وزاره الخارجيه تحدثت
عن ان زياره غوتيرش الى العراق تاتي
لتثمين الدبلوماسيه العراقيه في الانفتاح
على المحيط العربي وكذلك المجتمع الدولي
يضاف لها دور العراق في بعض القضايا ولعب
دور الوساطه الاقليميه في المنطقه هنا
يضاف الى كل ذلك الجانب الانساني وهو
المعني به بشكل مباشر وهو مخيمات النازحين
وعوده النازحين الى مناطق سكناهم ستكون
هناك زياره بحسب المصادر الى محافظه
نينوى الى احد المخيمات اضافه الى زياره
اخرى الى اقليم كردستان للقاء القاده
السياسيين هناك بالاضافه الى بحث ملف
النازحين يعني بما يخص ملف النازحين يعني
من يعني خاصه بموضوع المخيمات بعد هذه
الزيارات هل هنالك ربما من اتفاقيات مع
الحكومه العراقيه لدعمهم بالمزيد من
المساعدات او او ما الى ذلك
راويه بحسب المصادر ستكون هناك لقاءات
ثنائيه على مستوى الامين العام للامم
المتحده ووزير الخارجيه يتبعها بعض
اللقاءات الخاصه
باللجان الفنيه المعنيه باعاده النازحين
من جانب الخارجيه العراقيه وكذلك ربما
برنامج
وهو المسؤول عن عوده النازحين اضافه الى
كل ذلك ربما زياره غوتيرش ستاتي يعني
بجديه لعوده النازحين ستكون هناك جديه
لعوده النازحين الى مناطق سكناهم وبالتالي
ايضا ستجبر الحكومه العراقيه على الالتزام
بما اتفق عليه مع الامم المتحده وربما حتى
في تسريع عوده النازحين يضاف الى كل ذلك
هناك عوده للعوائل العراقيه الموجوده في
مخيم الهول في سوريا ربما سيتم بحث هذا
الموضوع مع الحكومه العراقيه خاصه انها
بدات بخطوات جديه لعوده مجموعه كبيره من
العوائل ربما سيسهم الامم المتحده من خلال
برامجها باعاده النازحين
والمتواجدين في المخيمات خارج العراق الى
العوده الى مناطق سكناهم شكرا جزيلا لك
سامر الكبيسي
افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان ان
ثلاثه فصائل معارضه سوريا في منطقه غصن
الزيتونه يسرقون المواد الاغاثيه
والانسانيه التي دخلت الى المنطقه عبر
المعابر الحدوديه واوضحت مصادر المرصد
السوري ايضا ان المتضررين لم يتلقوا حتى
الان او او حتى هذه اللحظه اي مساعدات
انسانيه امميه او عربيه
ذكر رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس
النواب مايكل مقول ان قرار مجلس النواب
الامريكي رقم 132 يقف الى جانب شعب تركيا
وسوريا بعد الزلزال المدمر وان هذا القرار
يحث الاداره على الاستمرار في الالتزام
بحمايه الشعب السوري ماكولا ابدى قلقه من
تقديم عدد من الدول مبادرات دبلوماسيه
للاسد معتبرا التطبيع مع نظامه خطا
استراتيجيا ومتهما الرئيس السوري باستغلال
الزلازل
التي حدثت
تستمر الاجهزه الامنيه بمدينه بنغازي
الليبيه في حملتها الموسعه ضد اوكار اوكار
الجريمه وضبط الامن المدينه بعد سنوات من
انتشار الفوضى وضعف سلطات الدوله في حمله
وصفت بالاكبر التفاصيل مع الزميل محمد
مسعود
اجراءات امنيه مشدده اعلنت وزاره الداخليه
وقياده الجيش في شرق البلاد البدء في
تنفيذها لضبط الامن والحد من ارتفاع معدل
الجريمه ببنغازي ثاني اكبر المدن الليبيه
الحمله هذه بتعليمات سيدي القائد العام
جميع جميع الظواهر السلبيه داخل بلديه
بنغازي من
مباني خارج الشرعيه خارج المخططات الاكشاك
الغير مرخصه
الطرق المقفله
المروجين المخدرات المروجين
الخمور الهجره الشرعيه السلاح بدون ترخيص
تجار الاسلحه جميع الظواهر السلبيه
بتعليمات من القائد العام لازم بغازي تنظف
لم يكن هذا الوجود الامني ممكنا في السابق
في عدد من مناطق المدينه بسبب انتشار
تجاره المخدرات والفساد قبل وصول الحمله
الامنيه لها والقضاء على مروجها
كانت لازم تكون ضرب يد من حديد لهذا لو
كان الفساد اللي نحن بصراحه فرحانين بها
كلها يعني شنو التمن والمدينه بنغازي
وجميع مدنوا لهم الخير ونتمنى لهم انفسنا
نحن يعني قبل كل شيء نحن اللي عايشين فيها
الارضيه هذا شيء ايجابي للدوله ومنظور اخر
ان الدوله يعني في الاحسن حتى صورتنا تبان
للاحسن ان الوضع للاسف اصبح كارثه يعني
انت في مكان بعض المناطق يعني
الدوله لها حق للقوه القاهره سموا فيها
يعني هي تملك القوه عرفت انها قوه القانون
بحكم قوه القانون يعني فالدوله نعم هي
اللي تجمع وهي نحن ميتينها طبعا
جزء من السلاح هو عمليه السلوك بعض
الاشخاص يعني محسوبين على مثلا على جهه
الامنيه برضو واعتقد انهم ماشيين في الشيء
هذا فانتمنى التوفيق للجميع يعني
حاصروا السلاح المنتشر وجمعه وتفعيله
قانون الجرائم الالكترونيه هي ابرز ملامح
الخطه الامنيه الجديده ببنغازي لازاله
الاكشاك والمباني غير المرخصه وتفعيل
اقسام المرور ومحاسبه رجال الشرطه
المتهمين في قضايا التزوير والفساد
مع تاييد وترحيب شعبي واسع باطلاق الخطه
الامنيه المشتركه بين الجيش والشرطه تبرز
تحديات تعاون المواطنين مع الحمله وقدره
الجهه الامنيه على الاستمرار فيها وان
يكون القانون كالموت لا يستثني احدا محمد
مسعود بنغازي العربيه
تصدر بولا تنوبو مرشح الحزب الحاكم في
نيجيريا سباق الانتخابات الرئاسيه بفوزه
على اثنين من اقرب منافسيه من خلال حصوله
على 8.8 مليون صوت بحسب النتائج الرسميه
نهائيه التي اعلنتها مفوضيه الانتخابات في
اكبر بلدان افريقيا من حيث التعداد
السكاني بالاضافه الى تصدره النتائج على
المستوى الوطني فقط حصد اتينوبو ايضا على
اكثر من 25% من الاصوات في ثلثي ولايه
البلاد على الاقل في 24 من اصل 36 ولايه
بالاضافه الى منطقه العاصمه ابوجا وهو
الشرط لابد منه لفوزه بالرئاسه
اعلنت سلطات مكافحه الحرائق في اليونان عن
ارتفاع حصيله ضحايا حادث اصطدام القطارين
في اليونان الى 32 قتيله
[موسيقى]
اعلنت جماعه اكسنا والمعنيه بالدفاع عن حق
الوصول الى الانترنت اعلنت ان الهند صدر
دول العالم للعام الخامس على التوالي في
فرد قطع للانترنت خلال عام 2022 بمعدل 84
قطع الانترنت حدث في الهند من اصل 187
انقطاع في بقيه دول العالم اما في المرتبه
الثانيه حلت اوكرانيا بعدما قطع الجيش
الروسي الوصول الى الانترنت نحو 22 مره
تلاتها ايران على اعقاب اندلاع الاحتجاجات
حيث قطعت السلطات الانترنت لاكثر من 18
مره خلال عامة
والان منسقات الامم المتحده في لبنان تدعو
الى انتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه دون تاخير
لتلبيه احتياجات الشعب حاولت شبكه سي ان
بي سي اللجوء الى تشاد جي بي تي لتنظيم
رحله سفر جاءت النتيجه انه لا يمكن
التعويل بشكل كامل على الاجوبه التي
يعطيها التطبيق
روبوت دردشه الذكاء الاصطناعي او كما يسمى
يكتب النثر والشعر والنصوص البرمجيه
باختصار انه يبدو كانسان يعترف حتى
باخطائه شبكه سي ان بي سي جربت التطبيق
على طريقتها لاختبار مدى دقه المعلومات
التي يقدمها حيث حاولت طلب تنظيم رحله سفر
فرد عليها بانها فكره رائعه ثم رشح لها
عده دول بناء على تفضيلاتها لكن في ختام
المحادثه خلصت تقرير الى انه لا يمكن
التعويل بشكل كامل على الاجوبه التي
يعطيها التطبيق فالخطا الفادح وقع حينما
قدم توصيه بفندق
على انه في العاصمه الاندونيسيه لكنه في
الحقيقه يقع في كندا
اما تذاكر السفر فلا يمكن لتطبيق الذكاء
الاصطناعي تقديم معلومات عن الرحلات
الحاليه او المساعده في حجزها او تحديد
اسعارها فقط يقدم اسماء شركات الطيران
وحتى حينما سئل الروبوت عن رايه في افضل
شركه طيران اكتفى بالاجابه انه ليس لديه
تفضيلات او اراء شخصيه وفوق ذلك اشار الى
افضل خمس شركات طيران حسب سكاي تراكس خلال
العام 20 21 الا ان القائمه وفق سي ان بي
سي تعود للعام 2019
وبشكل او باخر فان الروبوت قد وقع هذه
المره في حفرته فبعد ان حاول ان يهدد
العالم بالرموز النوويه وبهندسه وباء يفتك
بالعالم وانه يحلم بان يصبح انسانا ها هو
بحروفه يؤكد انه مجرد تطبيق ذكاء اصطناعي
الى العناوين
معارك عنيفه في بخموت ومحاور اخرى
واوكرانيا تتحدث عن احباط خمس وثمانين
هجوم روسيا
رصده 19 طائره تابعه للقوات الجويه
الصينيه في منطقه الدفاع الجوي التايوانيه
باول زياره له لبغداد منذ 6 سنوات كوتيرج
يدعو العراقيين لتجاوز التحديات
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]